this week we've also been talking about
getting to know our new neighborhood
tony and i learned the history of times
square and gail hopped on the ferris
wheel to see the sights
but this morning it's vlad's turn and he
gets all of the good assignments we sent
him on a food tour he tried some comfort
food at a familiar tour spot and he
checked out a local favorite vlad also
managed to find some calm amid the chaos
i can see the lights times square a
melting pot of cultures traditions and
hopes a place where dreams are etched in
lights
if you're hitting up the well-known food
spots chances are you'll go to junior's
restaurant for what's being called the
best cheesecake in the material world
that looks good
alan rosen is the third generation owner
of juniors
the whole story is really an american
success story my grandfather worked in a
soda shop when he was a kid with his
brother they bought a share in a
luncheonette they ran until 1948
they went broke because the war ended
times had changed they reopened on
election day 1950 is juniors for 71
years politicians and celebrities have
devoured junior's cheesecakes listen
it's a melting pot this restaurant and
so you'll see everybody from the ceo of
some major fortune 500 company to a
local
guy who works for sanitation or the mta
every president has come i mean if you
want to see regular people you go to
juniors right you know this is not a
fancy restaurant this is everybody's
restaurant
just one block north and beyond the
noise there's a little-known lunch spot
unless of course you're a local serbian
owner of writing guadalupe rivas and her
husband have owned the cuban restaurant
margon since 1987. your family works
here is it a bit
of the american dream for you and your
family
absolutely my mother lived here she
brought me to the united states when she
brought me here and i start getting the
sense of liberty opportunity we don't
have opportunity in our country but this
country opens the door to all of us and
to me is priceless
the menu blends rivas's dominican roots
with the original owner's cuban heritage
there are also some puerto rican dishes
mixed in
but the signature dish is still the
cubano
the only sandwich i'll break a diet for
you also have a lot of regulars yes the
guys that work in construction those are
my boys i love them
i'm everybody's mom so
you've got people who work on broadway
yes you've got
taxi drivers the cartoons the naked
cowboy comes here too so what can i say
yeah we got everything
[Music]
if what you need is a break from the
grind hop into ichidan a japanese
restaurant selling ramen with a side of
serenity all right all right satoshi
mitsuhashi works at the times square
location he showed me the ramen focus
booths
[Music]
you sit here and
for just a few moments while you enjoy
your ramen yes
everything is calm everything is quiet
yes before you go back out into the
crazy
[Music]
has 80 locations in japan and
specializes in tonkotsu or pork bone
ramen i like it very garlicky there's a
written order system to help maintain
the respectful silence
so you need to press the quarter button
call button okay once you've customized
your ramen you press the button at the
corner of the table
and a melody plays signaling to the
server that your order is ready
hi
somebody might say oh i wonder why i
can't see the face of my server we don't
want customers to get distracted what i
love about ichidan is that many times
restaurants that start in another
country
oftentimes try to be more american
but ichiran this is the same way it is
in japan yes as customers savor their
ramen in solitude i eagerly await my
taste of japan in times square
rishi
thank you
she means good delicious
[Music]
and so ends my scrumptious tour of just
some of the limitless cultures and
cuisines waiting to be explored in the
center of the universe
[Music]
at least for now
[Music]
can't wait for you all to try the ramen
and the cubanos i did bring back some
cheesecake for everybody for this entire
thank you some cheesecake from juniors
and look at this this is a bobble head
okay the only one of its kind that uh
alan gave to me it's the one that he
wanted us to have to display here
i thought it was me i said alan is this
me he goes what no it's the junior's
logo guy but i thought you know kind of
it does look like it doesn't look like
you if i were you i'd keep but i would
always like to have a bobble doll that
kind of looked like right i think that's
great
part of a good neighborhood is having
good people and good food and apparently
we have we have a lot of things now
unlike back in 57th street where it was
a little i didn't hard to find food
but i didn't time square had food like
that so thank you my eyes are open all
right where's the cheesecake
coming out it's in the kitchen